[Musik]
hier helfen das vorbei ungefähr auf die
hälfte der wettbewerbsbeiträge und ich
denke manchmal irgendwie ist das leben
zu kurz für so viele mittelmäßige filme
[Musik]
in diesem jahr von denen ungefähr acht
wettbewerbsfilm neuen wettbewerbsfilmen
ich bisher gesehen habe sind es immerhin
zwei die in erinnerung bleiben werden
der eine davon auch ein deutscher
beitrag und zwar von christian petzold
transit nach dem gleichnamigen roman von
anna seghers spielt wie der titel sagt
im transit und zwar in marseille zweiter
weltkrieg deutschen besetzung
frankreichs musst du ja die machen paris
zu benutzt überhaupt auf der straße dass
wir autos aus den 40ern werden oder so
lange dann ist alles von heute versucht
ein notariat vorher ruhe finden und wo
er sich verstecken konnte
selbstverständlich spielt das quasi ohne
kulisse und dadurch dass kommen sie
erfüllen eine schwebende aktualität
welches man n die mir sehr sehr gut
gefallen hat und das was mir wirklich
nicht so gut gefällt den erzähler aus
dem raum aalen auch als erzähler in den
film eingeführt das heißt ein neues auge
gefühlt um die deputation können jetzt
drückten sie ihre massive dadurch wird
es dann doch wieder historisiert in der
weise weil da jemand ist der allwissend
ist und uns diese geschichte die damit
ja deutlich vorbei erzählt und sich
nicht in diesem fluss vor der kamera
entfaltet
ihr film der mir am besten gefallen hat
ist verlass
es ist für mich der bemerkenswerteste
film in seiner ästhetischen radikalität
in der konsequenz in der la wir das
durchhält er selber nennt diesen film
eine rockoper rottweil jetzt sehe ich so
oper allemal reichen menschen vorkommen
kein dialog sprechen sammeln sich in
einem sprechgesang mit vielen
restaurants also wird sehr sehr viel
wiederholten male dass bayer in china
habe
hier spielt in den 70er jahren auf den
philippinen einem zeitpunkt wo herrschte
jetzt zwischen ja auch wieder und er
erzählt von einer frau die als hexe oder
eule beschimpft wird sie immer etwas
merkwürdig geworden ist weil man
verloren hat und ihr kind die beide
getötet wurden von diesen milizen sehr
gewalttätige geschichte aber im
gegensatz zu vielen anderen mehr oder
überhaupt der gewohnheit im team und
gewalt immer mir im blut und
zermatschten körpern zu zeigen gt wie
dies in seinen erzählungen von diesem
gewaltsamen ereignissen immer weg
familie und gibt ihnen dadurch aber noch
eine ganz andere
also spürbare beklemmende grausamkeit so
habe ich es jedenfalls empfunden
das ist sehr sehr grausam und deshalb
gleichzeitig aber auch eine große poesie
im filmemachen
[Musik]
naja es ist für mich der größte film des
festivals bisher online shops vielleicht
kommen ja zu diesem zwei film nie
wirklich herausragend aus dem
festivalprogramm ist er vielleicht kommt
ja noch der eine oder andere dazu ist
würde mich jedenfalls sehr freuen
[Musik]